The question is,
what do we do in situations like this
where we don't have data
between two separate dates?
Now, you might think,
Gee, let's interpolate.
And so we would estimate what a line
is between those two dates and
then fill in at each point
an interpolated value.
Why not do that?
Well, the truth of the matter is,
between these two dates,
there was no trading.
There really was no price for that data.
But if we're going to do something like,
for instance, compute a rolling average.
Or a mean over that data,
and there's nans there,
that'll wipe out our entire calculation.
So we can't leave it empty, but
we shouldn't interpolate it either.
So here's what we might do.
One thing that we can do,
is we fill forward,
going from, we go over all the data,
and when there's some missing data,
we fill forward from the last,
previous known value.
So for instance,
if we were to do that here,
we would get these values up until
that date, where it takes over there.
We would fill forward here,
and fill forward here.
Now notice there's a big gap between
there, and there's a big gap here, but
that realistically reflects what
was going on with the data.
Now the reason we do this instead of
the interpolation is the following.
Let's suppose we were looking for
patterns in the data and
we had rolled back time and
we were simulating history.
And let's suppose for
a moment we had this interpolation.
And let's suppose we're
right here in time and
we're trying to figure out
what's going to happen next.
We're looking for patterns and so on.
We're actually giving ourselves
information about the future.
We're observing that
the price is going up.
So if we were to make
a calculation here,
we would actually be
peeking into the future.
And that is not allowed.
We do not want to do that.
So we need to stick with only
filling forward a last known price.
If we do that then we're not
picking into the future.
So let's get rid of that ugly,
nasty picking into the future.
Okay, so now we've actually
filled in all our gaps and
we have continuous data from this
start point all the way to the end.
However, there still is missing
data here at the beginning.
And because we need some value here in
order to calculate rolling averages or
whatever sort of statistics we want to
do, it's better to have some value here.
Instead of not a number.
And in this case, we fill backwards.
So remember, if you are going to fill
your data to resolve problems with gaps,
fill forward first and
fill backward second.
That way you will avoid,
to the max extent possible,
picking into the future.
Now we'll hand it over to Dave.
And she's going to show you
how to do this in code.
Here's to you, Dave!